The answer is that only this
first statement is true, and
it shows that the empty
problem is undecidable.
The reduction is straightforward.
The output machine just runs the input
machine on the empty string.
And if it halts, it accepts.
If the input machine is in H bar that
means that it loops on the empty string.
And so will the output machine,
and it will accept nothing.
On the other hand, if the input machine
is not an HTM, that means it does halt.
And then the output machine
will accept everything.
Use pencil and paper to confirm that
this reduction works for yourself.
If you try to use a similar argument for
these next reductions, you'll find that
the machines output by the reduction,
except when you want them to loop or
reject, and loop or
reject when you want them to accept.
But, proof by Lack of imagination
isn't very satisfactory.
So let's actually show that if
these statements were true,
then we would get a contradiction.
If we could find these reductions,
then this one would directly imply that
the halting problem is decidable, and
this last one would imply that
the empty problem is decidable.
Let's erase the rest and
focus on this contradiction here.
We'll let R be the reduction such
that the description of the machine M
is in H if and
only if R of them is in E.
Then we let A be a recognizer for
the compliment of E.
The compliment of E is the set of
machines that except something.
We talked about how we can
recognize this language
with the dove tailing strategy before,
so assume that A implements that.
So to decide H we run M on empty
string and A on R of M in parallel.
If M halts on the empty string,
we recognize that fact.
And if it does not, we'll then R
of M must be an E complement so
A must recognize that.
And running these in parallel allows
us then to decide the halting problem.
One way or another,
we're going to ge tan answer
from one of these two machines.
Overall then,
the moral of the story is that you can't
mapping reduce a recognizable language,
like the halting problem to a
co-recognizable like the empty problem.
A co-recognizable language, by the way,
is one whose complement is recognizable.
And vice versa doesn't work either.
Keep this in mind when you're
trying to prove undecidability.